une technologie incroyable
il y a 20 ans, un engin aussi avancé
aurait été inimaginable, mais l'
idée d'extraterrestres attaquant notre
planète
poussant l'humanité au bord de l'
extinction le serait aussi alors que nous approchons de la
célébration du 20e anniversaire de la victoire du monde,
nous célébrons les héros du
guerre de 96 nous tous aujourd'hui, nous ne pouvons plus être
consumés par de petites différences
les paroles du président Whitmore nous ont unis est
une espèce et se répercuteront dans nos
cœurs pour toujours nous allons survivre
aujourd'hui nous célébrons notre fête de l'indépendance
même si notre monde avait été  réduits en cendres
et en décombres à partir de ces cendres ferait naître une
nouvelle ère de technologie de croissance et surtout d'
unité en 1998, les dirigeants des
nations du monde se sont réunis pour
établir une alliance mondiale pour la paix
mettant fin aux conflits séculaires
et à la méfiance politique des nouveaux unis
les nations continueraient à former l'
unité de défense mondiale unie dédiée à la
protection de la terre contre les menaces futures
Dav  id Levinson est aujourd'hui le directeur de
la défense de l'espace terrestre, tant de personnes
ont été perdues, car nous savons que c'était un
événement horrible dans lequel une grande partie du monde a
souffert et c'est ce qui nous a
réunis.
L'ESD a été un
grand effort de collaboration internationale et notre
objectif principal de  bien sûr est de nous garder en sécurité et
j'ai joué un rôle de premier plan dans le
développement de nombreux aspects de ce
système de défense, car vous savez qu'il a fallu un
effort énorme pour obtenir une grande base militaire sur la
lune
et ces unités en orbite qui ont un
gros coup de poing pour eux  Il y a 20 ans, ces
armes comme le canon destructeur de ville extraterrestre
ont été utilisées contre nous avec
des résultats dévastateurs.
puis découvrez comment nous pourrions utiliser l'espace de manière
défensive si nous devions rencontrer
quelqu'un de loin, mais n'oublions pas que
derrière toute cette technologie hybride se trouve
la force de l'United mil  itary un
ennemi commun a donné naissance à l'esprit humain
côte à côte des millions se sont rassemblés du
monde entier pour rejoindre l'ESD
grandi comme le fils d'une légende votre chemin est à
peu près tracé pour devenir autre chose
que le meilleur pilote de chasse était hors de
la question
je sais que je serais fier de ce que nous faisons
ici nous venons du monde entier
avec un seul objectif être le meilleur pilote de chasse
dans l'espace comme un privilège de représenter mon
pays la Chine et d'honorer la
mémoire de mes parents après les attentats  en 96, je
n'avais vraiment pas de place pour m'apitoyer sur
toi-même tu sais j'ai perdu quelqu'un bien-aimé
tu viens de faire ce que tu dois faire
surmonter maintenant je ne veux pas qu'ils reviennent
mais s'ils le font je me sens plutôt bien d'en
avoir un  ces combattants et les
faisant sauter du ciel,
le chasseur hybride est vraiment une merveille de
l'ingénierie moderne après
avoir identifié avec succès des dispositifs anti-gravité
sur le vaisseau spatial extraterrestre, l'ESD
a pu utiliser cette nouvelle technologie pour
créer un avion de chasse supérieur,
c'est unc  savoir si l'ex-président
Whitmore assistera à l'événement du 20e
anniversaire cette année, mais
n'oublions pas l'avertissement inlassable qu'il a
répété dans presque tous les discours après
quatre-vingt-seize, ce n'est pas une question de
retour des extraterrestres, c'est une question de quand
vous